if we ran the
earth experiment this funny little
experiment we're on
over and over and over and over a
million times and watch the evolution of
life
as it uh pans out how much variation
in the outcomes of that evolution do you
think we would see now
we should say that you are a computer
scientist
that's actually not such a bad question
for computer scientists because
we are building simulations of these
things and we are simulating evolution
and that's a difficult question to
answer in biology but we can build a
computational model
and run it million times and actually
answer that question how much variation
do we see when we when we simulate it
and um you know that's a little bit
beyond what we can do today but
but i think that we will see some
regularities uh and it took evolution
also
a really long time to get started and
then things accelerated really fast uh
towards the end but there are things
that need to be discovered and they
probably will be
over and over again like manipulation
of objects uh opposable thumbs and
and also some way to communicate maybe
orally like
whether you have speech it might be some
other kind of sounds
and and decision making but also vision
i has evolved many times various vision
systems have evolved
so we would see those kinds of solutions
i believe
emerge over and over again they may look
a little different but they they get the
job done
the really interesting question is would
we have primates would we have
humans or something that resembles
humans
uh and and would that be an apex of
evolution after a while
uh we don't know where we're going from
here but we certainly see
a lot of tool use and and building our
constructing our environment so
i think that we will get that uh we get
some
evolution producing some agents that can
do that manipulate the environment and
build
what do you think is special about
humans like if you were running the
simulation and you observe
humans emerge like these like tool
makers they start a fire and all stuff
start running around building buildings
and then running for president all those
kinds of things
uh what would be how would you detect
that
because you're like really busy as the
creator of this evolutionary
system so you don't have much time to
observe
like detect if any cool stuff came up
right
how would you detect humans well you are
running the simulation so
you also put in visualization and
measurement
techniques there so if you are looking
for
certain things like communication you'll
have detectors to find out whether
that's happening
even if it's a lot simulation and i
think that that's that's what
what we would do we know roughly what we
want
intelligent agents that communicate
cooperate
manipulate and we would build detections
and visualizations of those processes
yeah it and there's a lot of we'd have
to run it many times and
we have plenty of time to figure out how
we detect the interesting things
but also i think we do have to run it
many times because we don't quite know
what shape those will take and our
detectors may not be perfect
for them
you